foreign
foreign
foreign
uh good morning members cansters
officers and members of the public
um just to check that we are live
streaming before we go ahead
okay thank you
um a few matters of the meeting Protocol
no no fire alarm is scheduled this
morning so should the fire alarm sound
please take it seriously leave the room
by the nearest exit and meet by the
stand at the far end of the car park
if you wish to speak please raise your
hand on the boom microphone will be
brought over to you if you don't speak
into the microphone you will not be
heard on the live stream so please wait
for the microphone to reach you please
remain seated while speaking
please keep your points short and I ask
members not to repeat points that have
already been raised voting will be by a
show of hands unless there is a majority
request otherwise
should the meeting be adjourned any
filming mercies unless the expressed
permission from those being filmed has
previously been obtained
during any adjournment I would ask that
members the public and officers please
leave the room until the meeting
reconvenes
item one on the agenda then is apologies
for absence
do we have any apologies yes chair I
have apologies from councilors cook
Evans Jeffrey Parker Nutley Linda
petherick foden Thorne and Gribble
patch
do you get thank you
two on the agenda is to prove the
minutes of the council meetings of the
26th of July and the 6th of September as
in Pages 7 to 10 in the agenda
moved and seconded
um all those in in favor
thank you all those against
none and those abstentions please
that's carriature thank you
um no item three on the agenda is
announcement I'd like to start with an
announcement please I would like to put
on record my thanks to the vice chair uh
councilor Clarence for having stood in
for me on a number of occasions Council
meetings and external appointments
whilst I have been unwell he's done a
lot of work on my behalf for which I
thank him very much
I believe the executive member for
Holmes communities and cost of living
would like to address the council under
the announcements
uh thank you chair
recently we had the tragic news that a
coroner had concluded that the death of
a toddler in Rochdale was caused by a
spiritual condition caused by exposure
to mold in his home
ayb Shack's father repeatedly raised the
issue with their Rochdale Housing
Association but reportedly no action was
taken
having previously helped residents in my
ward to be re-housed due to unacceptable
levels of damp and mold on the wall
I've been looking into what action team
bridge District Council currently takes
in teambridge some 20 of the housing is
privately rented that's over twelve and
a half thousand homes
and some nine percent nearly six
thousand homes is rented from registered
providers of social housing
teambridge does not have the resource to
regularly inspect each and every one of
those nearly twenty thousand homes
we do have a team of some 3.2 full-time
equivalent officers who inspect
properties in reaction to complaints and
issues that are raised
officers will assess a property under
the housing legislation using the
housing health and safety rating system
which is a risk-based approach and looks
at potential hazards
there are 29 types of hazards that are
considered main ones including excess
cold Falls and trips structural collapse
electrics fire damp and mold
categorization of Hazard type is made by
assessing the likelihood of An
Occurrence that could cause harm over
the next 12 months and the range of
harms that could result and the
vulnerability of the residents those
types of Hazards
the main hazards are excess cold and
falls
where officers find a category 1 Hazard
the council has a duty to take action
and if Category 2 hazards are identified
they have a power to take action
we have recently served a civil penalty
notice including a category 1 dampened
mold hazard this was a fine for ten
thousand pounds in tinmouth on a
landlord for non-compliance with an
improvement notice
the majority of housing condition
complaints occur in the winter months
and we're expecting an increase in the
number of complaints and inquiries in
the coming weeks
in addition to complaints teambridge
also follows up the regular EPC reports
for Energy Efficiency that happen every
time a home is sold or rented
this identifies homes likely to feel
cold or maybe damp low Energy Efficiency
rated homes
are chased up by our officers a rented
property must have a minimum of an
e-rating on its EPC
and teambridge contract contacts sorry
landlords of non-compliant rated
properties
we are currently pursuing a number of
penalty notices on such properties
timbridge also has a Property agent
rating scheme inspects hmos and works
closely with the registered providers to
improve the condition of social housing
as well as private rented thank you
chair
thank you to councilor Wrigley
item four on the agenda is Declarations
of Interest I don't think we have any we
do uh councilor featherington
okay thank you chairman it's regarding
item six the report of the independent
renumation panel and the recommendations
from the procedures committee within the
procedures committee recommendations
there is a recommendation that the chair
of Standards receives an additional
responsibility allowance as I'm married
to the chair of Standards I think I need
to not to vote and also not join in the
discussion thank you thank you councilor
that's noted
any further Declarations of Interest no
do we have any public questions
no public questions Chad no public
questions thank you so item six on the
agenda is the for the council to
consider the report of the independent
remuneration panel and I understand that
leader would wish to move this
um thank you chairman and if I may I
just uh it may be helpful to counselor
John pedrick the recommendations are
intended to take effect from after the
elections in May so any decision of the
council today wouldn't be specific to
the current share of Standards chairman
in moving the recommendations set out on
page two and three 17 recommendations
yeah
yes there are 17 of them and moving the
recommendations on page two and three I
in particular want to pay thanks and
tribute to the independent remuneration
panel which is chaired by uh independent
uh member of the public Derek Phillips
who's here at the meeting today I know
the independent remuneration panel met
with and canvas the views and opinions
from a number of counselors and did a
lot of work in setting out its
recommendations which are then
considered by the prestigious committee
the procedures committees made some
different recommendations to council and
in part that's because we are in the
final few months of this Council period
and when the new council is elected in
May it may make some decisions about the
kind of committee structure it would
wish and we felt that the new Council if
it does have a different committee
structure we want to take advice from
independent remuneration panel at that
time and have a an allowances scheme
that reflected any changing in committee
structures for example whether it was a
single overview in scrutiny committee
whether governance and audit scrutiny
were merged and those things generally
so which aren't happening this side of
May
in particular I want to draw members
attention to recommendation one and this
is that the basic allowance uh is
increased uh by the average percentage
increase for local government employment
staff and that increase would be from
after the election in May so no one
today is voting on an increase in their
current allowances it would apply after
the elections
and that would help both to keep Pace
with uh general cost of living increases
so not significantly in line with
inflation and it encourages more people
to stand for election because there is
at least a reasonable allowance for the
work that councilors do
most of the other recommendations
chairman maintained the status quo and
they've not endorsed or accepted the
recommendations for change that were
made by the
independent remuneration panel so
broadly it's a status quo approach uh
then chairman
um on the page three
um just a couple that I want to talk
about item 10 is the special
responsibility allowance for the chair
of the standards committee procedures
committee felt that
a payment per meeting basis could could
result in an unregulated amount of money
being paid to the chair of a committee
and so the procedures committee felt it
was better to tie that with an existing
allowance and matched it to the chair of
audit scrutiny as a balance
and then at 16 the parental leave policy
is recommended to be adopted but with
the review so that it would look at
including foster care Leaf parental
leave and the requirement to ensure
confidentiality with regard to
legislation for the six-month rule
so for colleagues awareness as you might
know if a counselor is needing leave of
absence at the moment that's a decision
for counsel discussed in public that may
result in information which is personal
about a member's health or family
circumstances being discussed in an open
arena a procedures committee felt that
it was quite right that the decision was
made by Council but perhaps it ought to
be in an arena which is privately exempt
and how you balance the need for public
property against the personal
confidentiality of any Council so that's
a review that needs to be done and then
at item 17 chairman uh the present list
of approved duties uh within the scheme
is adopted and also the confirmation
there that a councilor attending a
Timber's district council meeting as an
observer rather than a member of the
body uh is able to claim the relevant
expense so for example if a council were
attending and meeting the executive they
weren't on the executive but we're just
simply attending to observe a debate not
necessarily to take part this clarifies
that they would be able to claim uh
their travel allowance where they so to
do chairman so in that and with that
explanation I move the recommendations
I've set out for 17 of them on pages two
and three chairman and councilor Jewish
seconded before the microphone came
thank you
councilor Boulevard
thank you a point of clarity please we
are normally recommend or
recommendations we normally receive
either to approve or to note I recommend
a a
proposal like this as the leader has
said this decision is open for the next
Administration to make its own decisions
about what is applied should we
therefore what do we mean therefore by
accepting the report given that our
normal approaches to either approve or
to note surely we should be noting this
report and leaving it for the next
Administration to apply it thank you
thank you Council Bluff and cancer con
it
thank you chairman
um so to accept as in to approve the
recommendations
I was explaining why the procedures
committee had recommended broadly a
status quo approach because a new
Council may consider a different
committee structure and then
on advice from the Independent
remuneration panel may come to a
different view about special
responsibility allowances
the procedures committee felt that that
shouldn't be dealt with now we should
continuously after the remaining six
months so to be clear
uh
the increase in the basic allowance from
May after the election
if the council today supports act should
vote in favor and that would apply to
the new Council was elected or returning
uh from May and then it's very clear
that the existing committee structure
and special responsibility allowances
for chairs and vice chairs what it will
be from May when those people are
appointed so that continues I was merely
highlighting at the council
procedures committee did not get into
because there's a separate conversation
on the Constitutional review whether
some committees are emerged or not the
procedures committee didn't get into
that conversation it broadly Fair we
should have a status growth so in direct
answers to the councilor Boulevard it is
a recommendation to accept or approve so
approve the recommendations are set out
chairman
thank you councilor
um does that answer your query
uh no basically if we're saying that
parts of this depend on the views of the
next Administration are we tying their
hands by what we're issuing now I have
no issues about the points made in here
it's a matter of principles that I am
asking about as I understand it the new
the new Council will have all the powers
necessary to review this as soon as as
soon as they take office is that right
councilor
foreign
yes chairman I totally clarified this
Council has to set
um
a remuneration policy which is doing
um I've clarified why we're mainly
proposing the status quo a new Council
may or may not choose to look at its
committees if it doesn't it's got a live
and active policy and if it does choose
to do it then it can do so and that's a
matter of the next Council we're not
leaving anything in a balance we're not
pushing anything kicking the cane down
the road we're dealing with matches now
and I've tried to explain why the
recommendations from the procedures
committee are different to those which
came from the Independent the advice
from the Independent remuneration panel
thank you chairman thank you Council
I think then we can go to the vote The
Proposal is the cancer gun has moved
that we accept
approve the 17 recommendations are set
out and and those as explained by
councilor comet
all those in favor please
oh thank you all those against
to and any abstentions please
that's character
thank you
we move on then to item seven
um
on the agenda the appointment of
independent persons I believe that
Democratic Services yesterday emailed to
all members
um the uh a briefing on the independent
persons explaining the recruitment
process and a brief biographical
description of each of the five whom we
are recommended to to appoint
um
the chair of Standards committee as you
as you heard earlier has sent her
apology she is unwell
um so I move that the recommendation of
the independent panel is is approved and
would ask for a second
thank you councilor Taylor
the posts were advertising the residence
newsletter and referenced in social
media 17 expressions of Interest
received resulting in 15 applications
and a short list of five we'll call for
interviewing the recommendation of the
panel is that all five are appointed so
can we go to the vote please those in
favor
oh it's border
point of order that's why I
yes indeed sorry I didn't see your hand
cancer Jewels well I I wasn't invited uh
and no one was invited to speak to him
um
that my one question is uh I've read the
CVS and uh
and and they are indeed what they are uh
people with uh with uh reputations I
wonder if uh if you could confirm that
all people who've applied have been
fully informed of uh of of the position
of the council uh and any uh pending
cases uh that that may tarnish the
reputation of the council uh in the
coming months uh I I asked so because uh
I uh as someone who's whose reputation
has been Trashed by this Council uh I'd
hate that to happen to uh well-meaning
uh individuals so I want to know that
the independent persons know what
they're letting themselves in for thank
you
I am not in a position to answer that
question I don't know if anybody else's
decision officer yes thank you chair
um
the situation is that these that the
applicants who were selected for
interview and
um were successful were informed that
confirmation of their appointments is a
matter for full Council
there will be depending on the outcome
of of today those intended to be a get
together with the chair of Standards
myself the deputy monitoring officer and
the five
um
uh successful applicant in order to
discuss matters going forward because
clearly
[Music]
um
one or more of them will be involved in
any uh complaints which are received in
respect to the members conduct at the
moment no discussions have been taken
place in respect of particular
individuals particular complaints
because that's not relevant to the
process that we were undergoing
does that answer your question
foreign
any further comments on this item
in which case can we now go to the votes
please with all those in favor
thank you those against
none and abstentions please
right
thank you I item 8 on the agenda is the
review of election fees and charges
Pages 47 to 60 in the in the document
pack again I understand the leader
wishes to
address this
thank you chairman uh the report is now
set out I'm sure members are ready
thank you
that's proposed by councilor Conant
seconded by councilor Dewhurst
any questions comments observations
councilor Boulevard
thank you can you confirm that these are
the actually the national uh rates that
we're talking about here or are they
specific for teambridge
cancer comic can you respond to that
okay the Electoral service
uh the Electoral Services officer will
respond
right but what we've done for comparison
is based among the current Stephen
County Council scale because that's the
only other one that we've got sight of
and we didn't think it was appropriate
based on national elections if they're
running on a different basis
Council Bluff and does that answer your
query
yes thank you I'm satisfied veterans
thank you uh councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um
would it be possible to recommend for
future consideration perhaps that we
look at similarly uh likewise District
councils in rural environments with um
spread out environments for for voters
because that would be more pertinent
perhaps than the whole Devon because
Devon obviously large connotations of
Exeter for instance whereas smaller
District councils like torridge
teambridge Etc would have a much more
comparative cost bearing thank you
sounds like a sensible suggestion to me
would the Electoral Service Officer like
to respond to that suggestion
let's ask again
um for reference um others are using
ours have we have shared ours with them
although they haven't shared with us so
um recently I think you'll find the
proposal is going to be East Devon
probably or exactly the same as ours
based on the same because we've shared
information there we're happy to share
others on
if there are no further comments can we
go to the vote please the leader
has been proposed and seconded
all those in favor
thank you all those against
none and do we have any abstentions
ic3 thank you
that's scary though
that's character thank you
um item nine on the agenda is the rural
England Prosperity fund covered by Pages
61-80
um in uh the the document pack and I
believe the executive member for economy
and jobs would like to say a word
okay
I'm assuming everybody's read reports so
I'd like to move to accept the
recommendations on block I would like to
thank everyone who's worked extremely
hard on bringing this support to Council
in what has been a short space of time
to satisfy the application timetable and
I think all members will appreciate the
amount of work that's gone into this and
I move to accept the recommendations
I'll set it do we have a second
thank you councilor Wrigley has seconded
that there are three recommendations
that members will have seen on page 61
of the document pack and that's what we
are being asked to to to vote on but
councilor Wrigley would like to make a
point uh thank you very much Chad
um I'd like to thank the officers who
have pulled this together
I'd like to thank the officers who have
pulled this together and remarkably
short space of time this is another
government initiative that landed on our
landed on our desks with a ludicrously
brief period to put it together this
report has to be put into government
tomorrow
so it is vital that um
we make sure everybody knows about it so
we've done briefings around the council
there is one slight Amendment to the
recommendations which I hope counselor
Jeffries will take in that
recommendation number three is slightly
inconsistent with the rest of the report
and it should read in consultation with
the executive members for economy and
business and communities in I.T in the
delegation Powers which is the usual
thing that we do
thank you Council Jeffries you happy
with that thank you um councilman I'll
come to you in a moment but the managing
director would like to make no
okay no cancelable event
can I have a third Clarity please
previously
um I am a Trustee of the new never term
community Transport Association
for that reason because of the trustee
I'm automatically made a director of
that I believe that because an issue in
here potentially may have been that it
may impact
on the new network community Transport
Association operations and the advice
from the
um from previous
situations
I've been I don't think I should take
part in any discussion or vote on this
so
um could I have Clarity that that will
be the case I should not take part in
any discussion or debate thank you with
admonishing officer like comment on that
please
not quite sorry
I'm not quite sure what what the the
issue is for the for the councilor I'm
not
at the end of the day I think that it's
a matter for eating individual in each
and every individual counselor to decide
whether they have an interest or not I'm
not quite but having said that I'm not
quite sure what what the specific issue
is I think this isn't this is a generic
um
report that covers a whole Gambit of
organizations across the district
so the organization that you belong to
will benefit no differently to any
others if it was to benefit at all
is that not the case
I don't want to put myself in a position
where I'm taking part in something which
I'm not qualified so to do
thank you councilor Wrigley
uh thank you chair um it's only because
there's a specific proposal in here that
is looking into improving transport for
the community that might involve the
community Transport organization
directly in terms of the implementation
I think that's the only concern is not
yet decided it's not yet determined it
could be implemented in a number of
different ways I think that that's the
only concern I personally don't see that
there's any conflict for uh um for
councilor Boulevard
any further common cancer person
thank you chairman yes I'd like to very
much welcome these proposals certainly
in the team value transport and
connectivity are very high on on the the
list I'm just wondering if the bid is
successful when are we likely to be able
to submit uh plans and programs to draw
down on the money what's the sort of
time scale unless I've missed it in the
report sorry
councilor Wrigley
foreign
there is
there is a three-year spend time frame
on this if I recall correctly the last
shared Prosperity bid we were promised
to know the results in October it's now
the end of November and we still don't
know that was supposed to be available
in April next year
so I would anticipate this being spring
next year in terms of where it goes
because of the
speed of having to pull this bid
together there is still a lot of work to
do in terms of the detail and the
implementation of this plan and in that
we will obviously be Consulting with all
the various organizations that could
take part in doing this so over the next
six months I would suggest thank you
any further comments or questions
if not we will proceed to the vote
we're asked to vote for the the three
recommendations of the slight Amendment
as pointed out by Council really on page
61 of the document pack all those in
favor please
foreign
thank you those against
none and those abstaining
is that carried
that's Curry chair thank you
we move on to item 10 on the agenda
uh LDV driver salaries and Market forces
um there are three recommendations and
you'll find on page 81 of the document
pack and I believe that the executive
member for recycling house or waste and
environmental health will address this
item start with
yes thank you chair uh recruitment of
large Goods Vehicle drivers has been
difficult since brexit so many drivers
return to their countries of origin
within the EU living a national shortage
of drivers other factors have been an
aging Workforce and a national backlog
of driver tests this has impacted on our
Council in terms of the Recruitment and
Retention of drivers in our recycling
waste and cleansing Department the
council has 52 LGV drivers on the
establishment and despite training
in-house applicants and an extensive
recruitment campaign we still have 10
vacancies a number of job opportunities
have been offered by the council and
despite the better working conditions
offered by the council these offers have
not been accepted
the drivers are currently on grade 18
with a salary of twenty three thousand
nine five three to twenty four thousand
nine two o and the proposal today is to
increase this to grade 21 on a salary of
28
371 to 29
439 from Thursday this week
there is a further seven roles two
supervisors and five charge hands whose
salaries are proposed to rise in the
commensurate manner I therefore proposed
this report as set out to increase LGB
drivers salaries from grade 18 to grade
21 to approve increases to related posts
to maintain great differentials and
finally to recommend that the garden
waste charge is increased to 55 pounds
to contribute towards the cost of these
pay increases and that of course will be
from the 1st of April next year
I hope everyone will join me in
supporting our Recycling and waste
drivers who do a great job for everyone
week in week out and always with a smile
thank you Jack thank you council do his
that is being proposed do I have a
second there please
seconded by councilor con it
do we have comments questions counselor
Boulevard
thank you two questions
firstly can you confirm how many of our
drivers came from uh different parts of
the world and have left the country and
left our Workforce
since the time and the second question
is
normally grading structure is based on
skill levels associated with doing your
job and the salary level is a different
application what we appear to be doing
here is upgrading to skill levels to
give the people a fully deserved and an
increase which I totally support
are we doing the right thing here should
we not just be looking at this salary
level
or what is the change in skill level
that we're implying through the changing
grade structure thank you
Council duhurst can you respond to those
two questions please I'm going to defer
to officers for for the second question
uh because I I think I'll pay grade
structure it is set by Council
um and and we can't
change that but I will leave officers to
comment on that as far as the first
question is concerned I'm not sure that
we necessarily had drivers from overseas
it's the impact of them leaving the
country uh with other uh driving
workforces that's had the impact in the
sense that the the major employers the
huge transport companies and the like
they lost vast numbers there's across
the whole range of local government
salaries that we're offering so we're
reviewing that to see how appropriate we
are and that piece of work is is just
about to go out so um hopefully that
answers the questions thank you
because of relevant
thank you for the detailed answer and I
accept the points that you've made I am
seriously concerned though that we are
potentially driving coach and horses to
a grading structure which recognizes
skill levels to give somebody a seller
increase and I totally agree these
people deserve the increases you're
proposing I just caution that we're
setting a Something In Motion which may
come back to bite us in the future thank
you
I think that's noted councilor McGregor
thank you chair
um
kind of really struggling with some of
the stuff that councilor Dewhurst has
run through now before I go there I
fully accept that we that we do need to
pay the drivers a better wage it's been
a it's been a concern for
the whole period of this this current
Administration that there's there's been
a a level for
um the waste team
um I think we differ slightly from the
others around us in that we are the one
Authority out of the four that employs
directly our staff within our own
function extra and East Devon and Torbay
use contractors so they have a different
facility available to them and it's up
to the contractor to make it work within
their within their contract
from our perspective as a as a council
when when we came to uh administering
2019 it was already clear that we were
struggling to recruit drivers then
um councilor Dewhurst denied in this
chamber the fact that brexit was to
blame and that drivers were going
elsewhere and being attracted by better
salaries when questioned directly and
that's a matter of record within Council
questions and answers
it's something that should have been
dealt with in 2009 we should have been
recruiting and we should have been
planning better in 2019 and I think it's
a shame that we're at this stage now
where actually we've got uh questions
marks over the salaries that we're
pushing up to when in actual fact this
is something should have been dealt with
nearly four years ago thank you chair
thank you councilman mcgregg uh Council
Patrick I've seen your your hand but I'd
like to give cancer Dewhurst a chance to
respond to councilor McGregor first
please
can we have a microphone down here
please
thank you chair for allowing me to come
back
in terms of uh of what I've said uh here
in this Council
um I'm so I certainly have no
recollection uh of of ever having said
the words that councilor McGregor uh has
um alluded to me uh the record will uh
we'll show that to be true or not
um in terms of
um other councils in in the area South
hams have an in house Workforce and
torbay's Workforce is a council owned
company so that that is is the
difference in terms of what this Council
has done for the workforce on our
recycling waste and cleansing workers
you will remember that one year ago we
were here and put a market forces
supplement for the entire Workforce
in in those departments so this Council
has reacted to to payments and we are a
good employer and I'm sure our Workforce
the very fact that so many of our
Workforce are really really long term
employers of this Council
shows what council of McGregor is
alluding to to be untrue thank you
councilor petherington but thank you
chairman uh yes I I'm looking at the
costings of this I mean I I fully agree
that we need to move this forward today
uh looking at the cost implications 92
000 this year 244 000 next year that's
what 330
000 pounds that we will have to find but
a percentage of that will come from the
increase in the garden waste bins
um how how much will that sort of take
off this this amount of 330 000 how many
green bins on there and how much will
that uh reduce the figure of 330 000
thank you
do you want to reply to that immediately
can we have a microphone please
thank you chair in in terms of the
revenue generated by the increase on the
waste bins of course we won't know until
the contracts uh with with our customers
as it were are cut come in so that's not
an answer that can actually be a well
that's not a question that can be
answered at this point uh we we have
estimates in terms of of what what that
is
um it is purely that the
um the the increase in the in the green
bins uh price uh it is going up it's
going up in line with inflation and I
think it's important that people
understand why that's going up and and
for the reason that it is supporting our
drivers salaries
kinds of Patrick
uh thank you Jim yeah I prefer to come
back on that if I may please because
let's base it on the actual number of
green bins this year and add the
increase rate onto that so what sort of
impact is it going to have please
sorry managing director thank you um
bottom of page 84.
um there is a the estimate is there 125
000 additional income depending on
subscription rates this case the Jew has
to set so the estimate is 125 000 as
Council juices said there is some
elasticity potentially on the demand of
that service around price
um we will see and report back as we
know um when the renewals come next year
uh whether that figure you know in the
um uh in the section 151 officers
reports whether that is an accurate
figure or not
thank you
thank you chairman yes I mean that
that's excellent um so we have to find
200 000 for this for next year
thank you uh councilor Connor no
chairman because
um what councilor pepper what cancer
pedrick is doing is adding the in your
cost now to next year's as I understand
it and set out in the report the India
cost for this year for this year is met
from vacancy rate savings being applied
to that cost next year the cost is set
out on page 84 at 244 850 pounds which
the Assumption of a five pound increase
in the green bin charge delivers the 125
so there's just over a hundred thousand
pounds to be found for next year and
that's what uh marching flickcroft Chief
Financial Officer is factoring into the
budget which will be coming to Council
in the next month or so so those things
will be factored in the reason why this
report is here today and not as part of
the budget is because we want to
increase the pay line to retain and
recruit drivers essentially to maintain
the one service every household gets
every week from us
and ordinarily we would not bring a
request to increase the green bins
outside of the budget but in order to
identify a contribution to that that's
why this has been put together now
chairman so it's a constant and budgeted
program there is a cost that has yet
will needs to be identified but will be
dealt with as part of the budget for
2023-24 which Martin flickroft is
currently working on with councilor
Keeling
thank you Council Eden
foreign
thank you very much
um in reply to cancer Boulevard's
comment about brexit I just want to say
that brexit is very clearly breaking
Britain it is the the herd of elephants
in the room here and being somebody that
likes evidence I had a quick check
online and according to the road haulage
Association uh pre-brexit we employed as
a country six hundred thousand hdv
drivers and that included 60 000 people
a tenth from EU member states who were
residing in Britain under the freedom of
movement rules this is an inevitable
inevitable and awful fact and I can only
hope now that we can see that the
conservatives and the labor party aren't
in favor of freedom of movement that the
party that I am very much still a member
of the liberal Democrats will continue
to say that we need freedom of movement
thank thank you
thanks cancer Eden I think councilor
Hocking
yeah thank you chair
um just a quick one really
um although I don't suppose any of us
should be sitting in this chamber and
denying
um any worker a pay increase and rightly
so deserved my problem is it's a
knock-on effect to everybody else you've
talked about keeping percentages and
differentials correct
what is the knock-on effect for the
um the people that actually pick up the
bins do the do the um the Sorting at the
roadside
um which on top of the drivers are they
also going to keep their differentials
right in which case what is the cost of
that
um I assume that when the the managing
director said that he was
um there was going to be a look at wages
across the board I'm assuming that he
means that they would look at the
differentials across the board because
otherwise we are going to start losing
um other workers other than drivers we
might have all the drivers but unless we
get all the workers that go with the
drivers
um we're not going to get anywhere so my
worry and my problem is as a union union
person is that we may we maintain the
differentials uh across the board and by
increasing one group you upset those
differentials and that is my big worry
and I'm assuming that the cost if we
implement this today is 92 700 just to
increase the driver's wages between now
and the end of April am I correct and if
so are those figures where is that money
coming from because you're not
implementing the increase in the green
bin until next April so perhaps you
could perhaps just tell us where the
actual increase is coming from bearing
in mind that we will keep getting told
that this Council has a black hole of 2
million pound thank you thank you
councilman Hawkins cancer Dewhurst would
you like to respond please yes thank you
chair
um yes in in reply to council the
hopking he will have just heard the
leader explain that the cost for this
year is born by the the fact that we
have been running 10 drivers short
essentially throughout the year and and
that has gone to pay the 92 700. in
terms of what this is this is a market
forces supplement because the market has
changed in terms of what drivers are
expecting to be paid and the council
will look at the as as the managing
director has said
jobs in general across this Council and
and the rest of the waste and cleansing
team in
due course this is
specifically for drivers thank you
uh councilor Malone
uh thank you
um I do actually know a couple of people
who would very much like these jobs at
either pay scale
um the problem being that they don't
have the uh the license to drive a
vehicle of of more than three and a half
tons as I believe they would require
um I just wonder whether um
it I mean it costs between and I know
this because I've taken it myself it
costs between two and a half and four
thousand pounds to get an hgv license at
an academy and uh that's if you pass on
the first or second time I I worry that
the sort of people were trying to
attract with these jobs are not the sort
of people who can afford to put their
family at this time uh four thousand
pound in a Hole uh and I wonder if a
more imaginative approach might be to
offer driver training to people that
want these jobs uh on the condition that
they stay in the job for a for for a
couple of years
um I I think that might be worth looking
into thank you
uh thank you councilor Jules would you
like to respond to that yes thank you uh
so in my introduction I did say that uh
this this Council has been offering
in-house training for for drivers so
that is something that we are already
doing uh we have an enviable record in
in terms of employing our staff uh we
have many people in the waste uh and uh
cleansing Department who have been
working for this Council for many many
years if if councilor Malone's friends
uh had applied and they've been a huge
advertising campaign jobs have been
advertised on the website
um if they'd been interested they could
have come along and applied for a job
with the council thank you
Council alone do you want to come back
on this too
could could councilor Dewhurst please
send me uh details of where they need to
reply because they haven't seen that and
I haven't seen it
please just just look on the website
it's there
no I haven't seen it well it's there I
can sure
cancer Hawking
yeah thank you chair for allowing me to
come back just one little question under
the 3.2 where it's legal it says Market
forces supplements do not form part of
the employee's standard contract terms
and conditions it is a temporary
addition to the contract of employment
they must be regularly reviewed and
withdrawn if Market forces change does
that mean that if these drivers do get
this granted today they could in the
future if Market forces change lose that
grading and be dropped back down in pay
thank you
yeah the answer to the question is yes
that's the market forces it's a
temporary uplift if Market forces change
the situation changes and upon review it
may well be that that additional income
or the market forces supplement is we've
moved
uh thank you uh councilor con it
thank you chairman and the point raised
by Castle talking is very valid and I'm
grateful for the head of the legal
services reply but also if colleagues
look at page 84
the second from bottom paragraph which
begins Market forces supplements it goes
on to pick up the point that councilor
Hocking had quite rightly identified and
it says although Market forces are
designed to be applied and reviewed
periodically and therefore May
potentially be removed if the market
shifts to lower salaries that in reality
given the shortage age profile and
competitive nature competitive nature of
roles we should expect that a Market
Force is uplift will be a long-term
commitment so I think it's important
that councilors realize that this
proposal is response to Market forces
and the council accepts that the market
forces supplement May well be there for
some time and I think in the past when
the council's applied Market forces
supplements in time the ordinary annual
pay increases catch up and they
sometimes diminish the market forces is
something that council is just going to
have to keep under review as the
managing director said but I hope that
clarifies for all colleagues and I'm
grateful to councilor Hocking for
raising that point because this isn't
going to be a short-term measure thank
you thank you Council councilor McGregor
thank you chair on the matter of um
people applying for the the roles as
loader driver and then you know I
appreciate councilor duhurst perhaps
isn't an expert on recruitment but it's
very very clear when you're putting in
adverts and you want to attract people
that you might want to train you have to
state that in the advert on the website
it doesn't say that it says you have to
have a category C license and a driver
CPC and a digital tachograph card so if
those three requirements are required
with no other option available
throughout the rest of the description
you are not going to attract people with
a three and a half ton license or
perhaps even a seven and a half ton
license who may have the other elements
because what you're not saying there is
that you have an in-house driver
training scheme and that is very very
clear so you are actually automatically
discounting people from applying and
that's a really important element and if
councilor Dewhurst is really genuinely
saying let's get people in and train
them then we need to change the advert
thank you
councilor Boulevard
thank you for allowing me to come back
um three basic questions following the
questions that others counselors have
raised
um I'm
increasingly concerned that we're using
a skill level rating through the grading
to affect the change and we should in
fact be having just specifically a
market rate adjustment
to give the numbers that the council
wants so people are fully aware of what
their salary base is and they can change
in the future
secondly can you tell me please we've
mentioned the quality of training that
we have and provide within the council
can you just tell me how many people are
currently undergoing that training to
become uh qualified drivers
and thirdly
we have a lot of numbers in here but
what we don't actually have is what is
that what is the proposed salary that
these or the salary bound I think I
think Council would you have set that
out in his in his presentation it's
nothing in the written paperwork
thank you
thank you chair
um in in terms of my presentation I
deliberately put the salary band in
because it wasn't in in the paper in the
paper
um I defer to officers on the other
questions
um I I don't know is the waste and
cleansing manager here yes
what's his name
uh the officer is going to respond
thanks
um yeah just to confirm on the training
numbers we've in the last 12. can you
speak into the microphone please sorry
is that better
so to confirm on the training numbers
you've had four in-house members of
Staff past their large Goods vehicle
license within the last 12 months
um they're all still with us three of
them are driving one of them as a
mechanic and we continue to Canvas
members of the rest of the team for
support with training which we do
provide
um and at this point in time we've got
10 names on the list from past
experience not all of those will go on
to be
um
suitable or capable or they might change
their mind or they struggle even with
the theory some of them but um it's a
good number that we've got now willing
to
go through the training and help us out
of the situation we're in
thank you councilor Morgan
um just just a couple of points really I
mean if we approve this today then
the increases happen on Thursday they
happen immediately
um
and I've got to say there's you know
there is an urgency for this we're 10
LGB drivers short vacancies that's 10
Crews that can't go out and we've all
been on the receiving end of the public
messaging us when they're whether when
their waste isn't collected
um you know people might not notice when
management don't turn up but they
certainly notice when their bins aren't
collected so I'd say this is a matter of
urgency let's get on and do it let's
give these guys and girls
which is a difficult job in in our lanes
that we've got in our streets that we've
got where people parking all over the
place so perhaps the grading is
important
um let's get on and pay them what they
deserve
um because it's Frontline workers that
are the most necessary and most obvious
when the front line work isn't done so
uh I'm very much in favor of this let's
go on and vote
thank you councilman councilor Swain
the question we now put
I moved to the question we now put which
question do the vote can we move to the
recommendation seconded
it has been proposed that we go to the
votes now uh we've been going around the
circles a bit
counselor hook did you wish to make a
final point
very briefly please
promise the uh
first of all thanks for various members
who've made good points and and we're
getting to the vote and that's good
um the three reasons we're faced with
this issue one of which we're we're
resolving ourselves the salary structure
and that's absolutely right but we
should there were two others the Aging
population of our Driving Force and and
and the impact of brexit and councilor
even did well to point out what she
pointed out and the impact of 60 000
drivers missing from the country
basically and the impact that has on us
can I suggest or can I ask if there's
any support around the chamber for that
particular point being pointed out in a
letter to the Prime Minister and our two
MPS and and anybody else you'd want to
receive it
um that there is a Major Impact here for
local authorities we are addressing it
in the way we can how will the
government help us in that final with
the financial impact that's causing I I
ask therefore if there's support around
the chamber for such a letter going uh
thank you councilor it has been proposed
that we moved to the vote but I'll give
cancer Dewhurst a chance to draw a line
under this please
thank you chair so I wrote a letter with
the leader of Torbay Council and the
leader of North Devon Council to the
Secretary of State
about this I'm quite happy to Canvas
um up those leaders again to write to
the prime minister
whoever
um if if this Council feels that's
a good thing to do
okay
right can we go back to the vote then
the the three recommendations are on
page 81 of the document pack
um
all those in favor please
looks unanimous any against any
abstentions
that's unanimous thank you
we move on then to item 11 on the agenda
committee seat allocation
I'm a little confused about this one
myself
I think councilor Haynes are you to
speak on this one councilor Haynes thank
you
thank you chairman
um
well members might know that the
independent group having gained one
counselor actually didn't gain any seats
however this is due to the fact that
previously our numbers were rounded up
and on this occasion it's been rounding
down in the sort of um you know the to
and fro I don't have any particular
problem with that I will reallocate the
places within our group I think the
beneficials of this are the South Devon
Alliance because they've managed to gain
an extra seat because of all the
roundings going on so I I would
certainly move the recommendation chair
I don't I don't have anything else to
say on it thank you is that that's the
recommendation on page four
yes
yes I was on the table as on the table
do we have a second for that please
uh councilor Boulevard to Second it any
comments or questions cancel the doors
thank you uh good to hear that South
have no lines of winners
um we uh we won't be taking up our place
on the standards committee because uh
due to our experience with it um
over the uh since 2019 it's uh appears
not to be fit for purpose uh doesn't
have the correct amount of introspection
and uh until until it can reflect on on
the actions it's taken and and uh the
advice that's been given from external
bodies uh then we won't be able to
partake in in that committee uh sorry
about that thank you
I think that's noted
event
just got in
in light of the last statement could
this
vacancy be allocated to the independent
group please
close to the leader I want to respond to
that please
thank you chairman but the seat is this
afternoon alliances they're entitled not
to fill it they're entitled to appoint
another counselor from a different group
to it if as I understand the regulation
if if the Holding Group doesn't the
point I think within a period of 30 days
the council is then able to allocate the
seat to an interested counselor and my
view would be to leave matters for the
30 days on the south Devon Alliance are
not
denied their opportunity to fit it even
though the group leader has very kindly
acknowledged today that they won't be
appointing that you know they may they
may change their mind they could change
their mind and the cancer should wait
require 30 days and then fill it
appropriately if it remains vacant thank
you chairman thank you can the
monitoring officer confirm that the
leaders write that it is there is a
30-day grace period for this
thank you
okay so that that is the proposal uh can
we go to a vote please those in favor
are those against
and any abstentions
that's character thank you very much
we moved to item 12 on the agenda which
has to do with Council representation on
the tool Bay and South Devon NHS
Foundation trust
two councilors have expressed interest
in representing
the Council on on the trust and I
understand there might be a nomination
for another
if I'm mistaken I'm mistaken
um
no okay in which case we have councilman
Gregor and councilor Russell who will
both be given two minutes to address the
council but I have to ask them both
please to leave the room and we'll call
them in one at a time to hear their two
minutes and ask them to remain outside
whilst the vote goes ahead clients
councilor McGregor and councilor Russell
to leave the room please
um
okay
um we're going to ask each of the
councilors to come in and address us for
two minutes as to why they should be
considered to represent teambridge
District Council on this trust and going
alphabetically I'm going to ask
councilor McGregor to come in first
foreign
the leader in the
uh
I think we should go ahead councilor
McGregor could you give us your two
minutes on how why you'd like to
represent teambridge District Council on
the this NHS Foundation trust how can he
vote if he's an officer oh okay
we will wait for a moment please beg
your pardon
make sure councilor Russell is
comfortable with the extra weight
foreign
Council McGregor
thank you chair I am I'm going to stay
here in my seat I think you know it's a
crowded room covered allowing and all
that so you have two minutes
um in terms of since my time on the
council uh as a as a newcomer uh back in
2019 I've gained a quite a lot of
experience one of those elements of
experience was work working with the
Devon Health and well-being board at
Devon County Council where I was
interacting extensively with members of
the NHS the NHS Foundation trusts
um the um
ccg and uh with the chief executive
during that period
um I was privy to a lot of information
that comes through these organizations
which isn't generally put out to
um
councils what I would like to do bearing
in mind and obviously with the time that
short is to change the way that we look
at the information that we're getting to
try and influence better how the NHS
Foundation trust interacts with councils
particularly through planning and with
the new local plan coming up how that is
going to impact on them commissioning of
services is really important
particularly in a community where as
noted by councilor Jeffries in in the
report that she presented earlier our
um populous is is growing more old by
the day and the proportion of people
over 50 is increasing uh generally so
it's about commissioning and how that
impacts on on the local area and as
Council councilor pedrick brought up a
planning meeting recently the NHS are
asking for funds now from planning so
it's to look at the whole thing and
actually represent the council to the
the uh the foundation trust board but
also to be able to feed back information
on how that looks and how it should
perhaps be be generated I'm more than
happy to work with any member of and any
group on getting the best deal possible
thank you that's about your two minutes
thank you very much indeed would you
mind leaving the room again and ask
councilor Russell to join us please
I don't want to go
where would you be comfortable
thank you Council Russell you have two
minutes right okay well um I've been a
member of this Council for over 40 years
and I've done quite a lot of various
things in that time but I've always
taken a particular interest in the NHS
and social services so I'll just confine
my address to you with my experience
with the NHS since the 1990s when I was
appointed a non-executive director of
South Devon Healthcare trust then I was
moved to uh to start the um the Exeter
and District Community NHS trust which
was newly formed with the NHS changes in
the legislation and we I had a statutory
Mental Health Hospital manager
responsibility reviewing the care and
sections of detained mental health and
learning disabled patients and during
that period I served as the Southwest
representative to the NHS trust
Foundation this was in the early days of
the NHS reforms at that time and I was
privileged to be able to influence
policy making at that time
I've chaired various Regional selection
panels for specialist registrar
appointments and regionals sitting
Regional sifting and interviewing panels
for future non-executive directors I've
chaired the Exeter Hospital's Heritage
Trust established for the protection And
archiving of historical medical records
um I I was a in 1998 I was appointed
honorary research fellow at the
department of medical history Exeter
University assisting the setting up of
continuing professional courses for the
management of medical records I was a
speaker at the 1990 GPS conference at
the NEC on the protection of historical
medical records and the fledgling
fledging electronic records Management
Systems which I suppose you're getting
familiar with today
um I I was also appointed a member of
off what but that's a different one
that's not really NHS of what of what
the water board well it's it's here and
there just about had two minutes thank
you well that's about it then chairman
thank you
[Music]
thank you very much councilor Russell
I'll ask you to leave leave the room
again please
very well counselors you have heard the
presentations from councilors McGregor
and councilor Russell
because I'm married to Andrew but on the
other hand I would never ever vote for a
conservative to be in charge of health
so does anybody mind just anyone oh
sorry did it I wouldn't vote for katori
but I'm married to Andrew so anyone have
a feeling about that yeah
sorry
I'm deaf as well
I can't read and I don't think it's a
matter for other people is for you to
decide if you think you have an interest
then you must declare it and not vote I
don't think you can put it to cancel
fine thank you I'm trying mind control
um mind control but I'm not voting the
thank you the vice chair would like to
make a point
uh members might be interested why I
didn't actually put myself up for this
particular post as you know I've been a
campaigner to try and save and still am
timoth Hospital from closure and I felt
that I didn't it was no good me putting
myself forward to sit on this when I
didn't actually know the position of
this Council I don't believe this
council's ever made the decision or not
to support uh the fight to keep timmouth
Hospital open and that's why I felt well
it's no good me putting my name up to
represent Cambridge District Council on
there on this NHS trust because I'm
supposed to be representing what new
members want so I'm happy to let these
people
fight it out in a straight vote but I
have to say that on the formation of the
new Council I would be interested in
representing uh if I can get myself
elected again in May I would be
interested in representing this Council
on this post in the future if I can get
myself elected and we can get this
Council to get behind saving timoth
Hospital thank you thank you Council
parents that is noted members we as I
said that we've heard from councils
McGregor and councilor Russell it is now
simply up to us in a show of hands I'll
go in the same order as
a pardon
could we have a confidential vote why
is that is that a proposal yeah is that
second dude
councilor hook has seconded
Council Gordon hook has seconded
so
can we go to a confidential vote
you've got a
consensus first you've had a proposal in
the second year
the council needs to vote on that
proposal okay can we we've had a
proposal that this goes to a
confidential vote those in favor of it
being a confidential vote please raise
your hand
11 12.
is that what colleagues make it 12.
those against a confidential vote
eight nine ten eleven twelve thirteen
I'll make that do you make it yeah
you know with a majority of one the
proposal has been rejected so we will
not have a confidential vote we shall
have a show of hands and going in the
same order at alphabetical order as we
went for the presentations those in
favor of council councilor McGregor
being tdc's representation on the tall
Bay and South Devon NHS Foundation trust
please raise your hand
because you raise your hand clearly
thank you
can you still put your hands up again
that hands up again so we can just check
the counter please
six seven eight
nine
do you make it nine twist and Chris yeah
nine
thank you uh those in favor of uh
councilor Russell being our
representative on the tour Bay in South
Devon NHS Foundation trust please raise
your hands
five six
and make that
so that's nine to go in favor of
councilman mcgregories I therefore this
Council has
appointed councilor McGregor to be our
representative on the south Devon AHS
Foundation trust would you ask them to
come back in please
yeah
yeah
um
I don't know why that wasn't discussed
in advance
um thank you councilors McGregor and
councilor Russell it is my duties chair
to um give you the results of the
election and I can say that uh
teenbridge District Council has elected
councilor McGregor to be our
representative on the tall Bay and South
Devon NHS Foundation trust I'd like to
thank both councilors for offering up
their services for this very important
role councilor McGregor
thank you Joe um I would just like to
thank all my colleagues for their
support and also to thank councilor
Russell for participating in the in the
uh the vote and and the um process to
try and get this rule filled thank you
thank you
councilor Russell has not indicated any
intent wish to say anything so we'll
move on then to item 13 on our agenda
which is a notice of motion which
councilor Boulevard will present notices
of motion are referred to the
appropriate committee meeting
if two-thirds of this meeting today wish
to debate it then we will debate it
today otherwise it will be referred to
the executive councilor Boulevard
thank you uh thank you Ken thank you for
the opportunity to bring this motion
forward and I'm grateful to those
members who supported this motion
there are few if any in this chamber who
will be able to recall a time when God
saved the queen was not our national
anthem
we have all been beneficiaries of the
vast changes that are taking place in
Cambridge since her majesty took the
throne in 1953.
a longest serving Monarch a queen who
dedicated all her the long Reign to her
people and someone who we remembered
with great affection by Future
Generations
well I believe it is appropriate and
deserve that we recognize the patting of
our Queen by planting a tree there will
be a highlight for future Generations
who will be able to identify with these
times
we also welcome the new King King
Charles III who has stood by his
mother's side throughout her long Reign
supporting her and preparing for his new
role I think it's appropriate
at the same time as commend
commemorating his mother
we plant a different complementary tree
to acknowledge the new king I therefore
propose that this Council approves the
purchase and planting of two appropriate
trees and that's that on behalf of all
residents of teambridge that the cost is
paid for by a 50 pound contribution from
each councilor's Community Fund thank
you
because you've heard the proposal
um
councilor Eden is proposing that we
debate it
was in the motion Council government has
just proposed about that contribution
being made and I clarify that please
it's an invitation to contribute to this
invitation thank you
uh Council Eden has proposed that we
debate this today if two-thirds of the
people in the room wish to debate it
then we shall do so those in favor of
debating this notice of motion
pardon oh we haven't got I haven't got a
second It Is seconded by councilman
McGregor
those in favor of debating the notice of
motion today rather than sending it to
the executive those in favor of debating
today please raise your hands
thank you those against debating it
today and referring it to the executive
so there wasn't two-thirds in favor of
debating so
um chair through you
it's so the notion councilor Boulevard's
notice of motion is referred to the
executive
thank you councilors
item 14 on our agenda um
I just wanted people want to
a very brief Comfort break
could we have a brief Comfort break
please it is now by my watch 25 pass can
we come back in 10 minutes at 25 to 25
to 12 please
put put my microphone on uh thank you
very much uh thanks for coming back we
are coming to item 14 on the agenda but
just before we do may I remind
councilors please of the finance
briefing that will follow this meeting
um we will I've agreed with the Martin
flitcroft we'll go straight into the
finance briefing at the end of this
meeting rather than take a break because
it's quite possible that colleagues
might be
leave the site and come back late so
we'll go straight into the finance
briefing as soon as this meeting ends
so we come to item 14 cancel the
questions
um
we have a number of questions from
Council of doors
do you wish to thank you
hi thanks for uh thanks for that the uh
the first question I put forward uh was
for the chair of Standards um it was
about the advice that I was given from
the monitoring officer stating that if I
took part in a debate that that will
constitute a criminal uh offense and uh
is the chair of Standards to confirm if
that advice was correct and the answer
was yes I can confirm the monitoring
officer's guidance was correct I'd like
to put on record of supplementary
question to that because at the
extraordinary council meeting on the
17th of November the managing director
stated that if you had a pecuniary
interest you could be committing your
criminal offense but further stated in
that meeting that my interest was a
registerable interest
um
as as noted earlier in the meeting today
uh that when counselor bulovan asked the
question uh he was given the advice it's
down to members uh to
um to uh consider their interests uh so
I'm still wondering why I was approached
by the monitoring officer and told uh
that uh that my interests were
constituted the criminal offense uh it's
clear to me that an unpaid director of a
CBS isn't a pecuniary interest is
defined by the localism ACT uh so can I
uh can I ask to be referred to the
specific legal Provisions uh that could
have made my conduct as an unpaid
director in the July full council
meeting a criminal defense is that
supplementary question directed to
councilor Linda Patrick uh did she
answered it I'd very happily take
clarification from the monitoring
officer as he's here today
uh yes please
Council of doors is fully aware that
we've engaged in quite considerable
written correspondence on this where
he's had complete and utter advice from
me which Remains the case Council of
doors continually conveniently
overlooks the fact that your code of
conduct that's been adopted by this
council at appendix a includes unpaid
directorships as a disclosable pecuniary
interest
the localism ACT is the starting point
the localism ACT also provides at
section 33 I believe for this Council to
add to
um
its interests and what it considers to
be disclosable peculiar interests or
other matters in its code of conduct
which it has done that is what binds
Council adores and that is the basis of
the advice that I gave him it makes it
clear appendix 10 in your code of
conduct that a an unpaid directorship is
a disclosable pecuniary interest as such
any member with a disclosable peculiar
interest should not take part in the
meeting should not vote and should
depart from the center from the meeting
venue
failing to do so and should that member
take part in the debate that as it
states in the localism ACT is a criminal
offense he was merely guided on that the
decision ultimately is one for him and
each and every one of you to make
um
that remains a case Jeff
and my supplementary I'll put in writing
because I would like to be referred to
the specific legal Provisions that made
my conduct and as an unpaid director of
the CBS a criminal offense because I'm
afraid the monitoring officer is
misleading the council
you will put your supplementary question
in writing yes thank you very much
can we move on to your second question
please cancel the doors yes my second
question was to cancel the uh Nina
Jeffries uh about the Steering group uh
for the Market Hall and Alexandra
theater uh why I was excluded uh from
that meeting having repeatedly asked to
be involved in that uh and I'm going to
get an answer in a verbal response yes
uh Council Jeffries has indicated she
will give a verbal response
foreign
thank you councilor Dawes
um your expertise in the field is
welcomed
um initially the sessions were being
held online uh through Zoom or teams the
groups were very small and with limited
numbers of members to
um
so to remove the duplication of having
members there
um and to allow discussion between
stakeholders who may not be used to be
in a formal setting we had smaller
groups so essentially to put people at
ease we held three Steering group
meetings online they were following the
terms of reference framework for that
group that was set out meeting four was
due to be on the 18th of May and that
had to be delayed as I understand
due to the three design options not
being ready
um and also as I understand and the
Steering group work was subsequently
suspended whilst additional work was
undertaken regarding inflation and
additional costs and the plan was to
widen the scope of Engagement so that
was always the plan was to invite
um members with particular expertise
such as yours to come in at later dates
to discuss
um work where it was relevant so um that
was including writing members with
specialist knowledge at a later date
um once we had the preferred design
options so we never really got to that
stage and therefore ensuring that the
right expertise is involved at the right
time I hope that answers your question
thank you thank you would it be possible
to have a written uh version of that
answer the police yes that's fine yeah
and and subsequently I have a
supplementary because I I do I do know
the answer and I will look forward to
getting it in in writing uh the uh your
desire to have a all the meeting is
perfectly fine I can understand that
that doesn't detract from my rights as a
counselor to attend meetings should I
should I feel it is within my sort of
remit of of a council and to do business
so what I asked for is uh how would that
how that decision was arrived at and how
is that consistent with the Local
Government Act 1972 amended and the
local authorities executive agreements
meeting in the access to information
England regulations 2012.
foreign
thank you
um I'll provide a written answer if
that's okay with you
is that exactly yes thank you I'd like
it in writing thank you very much
um your next question uh question three
uh relating to the spend on the future
High Street fund yes so I I asked a
question uh wasn't entirely too sure who
to ask the question to uh but it was
relating to spend uh of of of
taxpayer money to get to rebirth level
four uh for the uh the new Cinema uh so
uh there's a very full answer given by
the leader which which I appreciate the
uh over 500 000 pounds has been spent
already on on a project that is yet to
receive planning permission I don't
understand the uh the response to the
question because uh the answer seems to
contradict itself uh about the money
spent saying that uh 300 uh
1284 have been spent and then in the
following paragraph it says uh uh none
of this money has actually yet been
spent the uh the program of the cinema
commenced on the 13th of the 6th 2022 uh
and it is to conclude on 25th of the 5th
2023 Reba stage 4 is a technical
designer stage normally undertaken when
planning consent is granted uh what what
I would like to know is why why the
council is plowing on with a a project
that has yet to receive planning
permission and and what element of
taxpayer fund is at risk should plan
your permission not be granted for this
project which has huge huge challenges
in in just the planning aspects
cancer Connor can you respond to that
microphone please
thank you chairman we'll provide a
written response thank you
cancer doors you will be provided with
the written response is that acceptable
yes I'll look forward to that thank you
the um
my next question uh was uh so Council uh
asking uh the leader if he would
consider proposal for an alternative
multi-stream Cinema as drafted by
Community groups uh working with the TDC
planning policies now the response was
as a local Authority teambridge will
consider all planning applications so my
my supplementary is that wasn't actually
what I was asking I I know uh groups can
go out there and put forward planning
applications but does every counselor
here would have seen from their inbox
there is a scheme that's been designed
uh by Jeremy Newcombe for a cinema that
is a three Screen Cinema with one retail
unit
uh underneath it on the footprint of the
new look building a scheme that has much
less impact on a listed building a
scheme that would be defined as viable
by the report I know this Council is its
third party reports the report that was
presented by the cinema consultants and
uh I I would like to know why the Cairns
uh well I would like to know that the
council will consider that because uh I
would also encourage all councilors here
to look at that scheme because the the
the significant hurdles that the
planning application has to get over uh
would not be uh would not be as high
with the alternative uh scheme so what
what I would like to know is that the
council will consider that scheme and
I'd like to know why the council has not
consulted with the creative community
and creatives in the town as it's plowed
on with this unviable un undefendable uh
car bunker liver project
and can't look on it
well I'm not sure where to go with that
particular rambling supplementary
chairman uh but in essence I think my
response provides the answer to the
question which was asked rather than
narrow extract that cancel the doors
re-read to the council
um the council is progressing with the
project in just I think a week ago
councilor confirmed his intention to
continue with the future is she fund
program and the cinema funding
it's very clear here that the local
planning Authority teambridge is
required to consider all planning
applications the next sentence also
points out that alongside that
responsibility the council would also
need to consider separately matters
relating to its property and lands
Holdings where proposals are made for
Council Asics so there are two functions
of the council one is a planning
Authority one as a land holder the
council was also established over so
many months years in fact his intention
to invest over nine million pounds of
government grant into the future High
Street front of support and grow the
economy of Newton Abbott to increase
footfall to support retail protect jobs
and do many things so while I understand
that Council of doors wishes to promote
and further a different scheme at the
moment here as a council this Council
has supported the investment for the
cinema as set out and I'm not going to
comment on its planning merits for fear
of predetermination chairman I'm a sub
member of the planning committee I'm not
going to comment on the planning notes
scheme I can well understand that
Council of doors wishes to promote his
own scheme for which he is a member of a
different organization I'm not going to
comment on that chairman my answer is my
answer both they're substantive and
supplementary question thank you
chairman thank you constantly
cancer doors can be moved on to your
fifth question yeah my fifth question
was would the leader of the council
confirm me to resign with immediate
effect if TDC was a judge to have
operated unlawfully and a leader has
indicated that you will give a verbal
response well chairman this is a
hypothetical question so in the
hypothetical circumstances that there
was such a report I would read it and
give the details due consideration at
the time thank you chairman
yeah my supplementary to that is that no
functioning organization can operate
outside of the law uh is that a question
would you please allow me to get past
one sentence to pose the actual question
so would the leader confirm that he
agrees with that statement
no functioning organization can operate
outside of the law do you agree with
that I'm not to engage in hypothetical
discussion either as a supplementary as
not that's a supplementary question you
you are you determined in response to
that I'm not going to engage in
hypothetical conversations with cancer
doors thank you
uh question six
uh questions to councilor Gary Taylor
can you confirm that the previously
scrapped wolverd dpd master plan is
being revived uh Council Taylor has
indicated he will give a verbal response
councilor Taylor
thank you for your questions uh
councilor doors
what I can confirm is that the
walborough dpd master plan which was
halted in February 2020 realizing a
saving to the Council of 122
000 pounds is not being revived
as noted in the minutes of the February
2020 meeting many of the issues within
the scope of the dpd were to be
considered in the Now imminent's new
local plan along with other policies
that would benefit the whole of the
district such as tackling climate change
as members will know the new local plan
has been making good progress over this
summer in Autumn and will come before
full Council on the 15th of December to
prepare both the dpd and the new local
plan together would not only have
consumed additional offer officer
resources and finances it would have
also delayed the local development
scheme the timetable for the elements of
the new local plan
yeah my supplementary to that is the uh
the saving of 120 000 pounds sorry it's
been so long since it was uh Scott could
ask if that included the uh the spend of
sixty thousand pounds on the uh on the
environmental survey that concluded that
the greater horseshoe populated the area
vastly
in response I can I can to tell Council
doors that the full breakdown of all of
the costs that were incurred in the
production of the dpd can be found in
the minutes of the meeting or in the
report
cancer doors yeah okay we'll move on to
question seven
um there's um
a citizen's body I can't quite remember
the name actually uh the the group
that's been put forward together by the
council uh of uh of members of the
public to consult on the plan uh for
walborough and na3 can you confirm that
the interested parties such as Parish
councils residents associations are more
counselors will be included in this
process
so so question seven if I could read it
out uh to uh to members is can you
confirm that the representative bodies
of the electorate residence associations
and Parish councils along with Ward
councilors will be consulted in this
process
um
in terms of the process given that the
dpd is not to be revived uh is
perhaps not really what I've recently
prepared for the for the answer for the
question but what I can say is that the
walborough residence Association in
abbots occurs well Parish Council have
already submitted a number of
comprehensive responses to the various
parts of our new local plan over an
extended period for which I would like
to offer my thanks I hope they will
continue to respond along with those
many other individuals representative
bodies and Parish councils when
consultation on the final draft of the
new local plan is launched in January
which will continue many policies which
I'm sure will be recognized as
applicable to development close to the
residents they represent in addition to
those saved policies including those for
na3 contained in the current local plan
can you uh question number eight can you
publish the methodology of constructing
the citizens assembly and how it might
represent public opinion on an A3
so in answer to that uh uh a Citizens
assembly or citizens panel has been
formed to take part in six design code
workshops regarding na1 Halton Barn to
the northwest of Newton Abbot with the
first of these taking place last Friday
there were 20 attendees on the day and
the workshop was well received many of
the themes discussed would have chimed
with residents of other areas of Newton
Abbot including neighbors of the na3
development area with topics such as
long-range landscape views connecting to
Nature and space to meet friends and
Neighbors
I can confirm that further details on
this initiative will be published in the
members newsletter with the update
briefings with local councilors also
being arranged
my supplementary to that is the original
question can you publish the methodology
of constructing the citizens assembly
Council Taylor
yes so that will be published
does the answer to those but I can I can
also report chair that the district
district-wide design code is now in
draft form and is being ready to be
appended to the new local plan officers
are also due to meet with the design
Council design review panel in the next
two weeks to review progress with the
overall year-long project as part of the
national design code Pathfinders program
for which teambridge was selected as one
of only 25 councils across the country
yes uh Mike question number nine is sort
of irrelevant really because the uh the
question is uh how will the council
ensure that their own must plan for an
A3 will be implemented there is no must
plan for an A3 uh it's it's fallen into
into local planning policy so it's being
done piecemeal uh but I'd be interested
to know how uh how how the council would
implement the master plan if there were
one
thank you
okay
just perhaps if we could move on also to
if I could answer it nine and ten
together uh so question 10 is how will
TDC Howard teambridge get around the
plan that PCL planning put forward as uh
with uh in the same at the same time so
chair questions nine or ten are both
based on the incorrect assumption that
the walbro dpd master plan that was
halted in February 2020 would now be
revived with your permission therefore I
propose to answer these two linked
questions with a single response an
excerpt from a paragraph for the record
paragraph 26 page nine
from from the letter of the 3rd of June
2020 from the decision officer of what
was then the ministry of housing
communities and local government to
David Seton at PCL planning regarding
pcr's application for an award of cost
against costs against teambridge
District Council in the matter of the
allowed planning Appeal on land at
walbro Barton by the secretary of state
which states in relation to master
planning this has been the subject of
lengthy discussions and negotiations
during the during the application
process with iterations of a master plan
evolving during the consideration of the
application
given the requirements of policy na3 and
the importance of the document to the
proposed development it was not
unreasonable for the council to give
close scrutiny to its content and to the
processes that led to its production
the council also undertook its own
Master planning exercise seeking to
proactively test sustainable options for
overall delivery of the allocated site
in the event the council was satisfied
that the final iteration of the
appellant's master plan was sufficiently
close to its aspirations for the site
that further matters could be left as
reserved matters
this was considered a reasonable stance
for teambridge to take and with no time
spent at the inquiry on this matter and
with all other matters taken into
account I'm pleased to remind members
that No Award of costs were made against
this District Council
to be clear that while a number of
development companies are now engaging
with each other and the council in
bringing forward and delivering an A3
there is not a requirement for a further
overarching planning document to be
prepared for this Newton Abbott
Development Area thank you chair
yes thank you for answering both those
questions in one go I do have a
supplementary for that which is uh uh I
I dust the the counselor concern to to
reflect on the fact that he he's he's
reiterating uh the the the the
statements from uh from from as we know
uh government departments that are
enforcing development on uh local
councils and and to reflect on the fact
that without a master plan it's
impossible to uh to for this Council to
carry out its obligations under an
environmental and a climate change
emergency with any credibility uh total
failing failing and failure of this
Administration uh I'd ask every member
of this Council to reflect on that
and and I was a chair I would say that
uh Council adult is obviously not
listening to the responses that I'm
giving him there there is a master plan
for this area and certainly I do reflect
on the fact that it's the secretary of
state that is giving judgment on on na3
and I have a lot of sympathy with the
residents of the area in a better scheme
could not have come forward for that
site
no further supplementary Council doors
and that was my supplementary thank you
uh that brings us to the end of item 14
on our agenda
um it is recommended that under Section
100a full of the Local Government Act
1972 the press and public be excluded
from the meeting now during
consideration of the following item on
the grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraphs three of financial
matters of part one of schedule 12a of
the ACT I propose therefore that we move
into a part two session do I have a
second for that please councilor Wrigley
thank you uh can we have a show of hands
those in favor of moving into part two
I don't know
okay
anybody against moving into part two
do we have any abstentions
[Laughter]
that's carrier that is carried so we
move into part two
um for the consideration of the report
from the team bridge District Council
Housing Development and I asked the
executive member for homes communities
and cost of living to propose the
recommendation